welcome to our Kickstarter campaign
video for goodbye promise my name is
david brennan I'm a filmmaker the guy
but I'd up my first feature film ins had
a night before the wedding I also
co-host film courage on that we talk
radio with with them the fabulous Karen
warden is holding the camera and I want
to introduce you to my god here I would
I let you out let you take it away a
little bit my name's Richard Jacob I
wasn't an executive producer on that
front of money also I'm the executive
producer on a current phone kept my
promise what we're going to do right now
I was we actually have a little sneak
peek this is the first time anyone you
included have an opportunity to see our
teaser trailer Serena we're going to
start with the teaser trailer rather go
right to it right now and when we're
done with that we're going to come back
and not a few won't work Sadie
every success story seems to have this
sob story in the beginning so cry me a
river let me hear your sob story one of
my good friends let me sleep on his
couch for like three months mills crazy
miss spring is coming off the couch with
it oh yeah MattyB shout out to my man
Maddie me mad at me I was let out here I
meant to be out here it's beautiful out
here and I wanted you to know then I
tried
you
you know welcome back thank you for
taking the time to view our our teaser
trailer goodbye promise we really
appreciate your interest in this overall
Kickstarter campaign and to be honest
with you what's happening is is Richard
I have been going back and forth trying
to trying to get this thing going trying
to try to put this together and and I've
been stumbling and he's been something a
little bit we hate being in front of the
camera but rather be behind the camera
and he's like Dave you know what I'm
gonna go ahead and just give you a
fortune cookie and it's a calm you down
or whatever and I i just opened this and
care does it over the center that he
doesn't know that says it says you were
headed in the right direction trust your
instincts so with that we're just good
we're just going to keep moving forward
with this phobia we're going to get more
this video by the way you want to go
back and watch the teaser trailer again
we certainly don't mind that I don't
mind yeah but we do want to talk a
little bit about the trailer yeah the
main guy he once he has a dream to come
out to LA to make felons who wants to be
an actor and get a plan and he wanted to
get a seven-year gold set up and if he
didn't make it in seven years he's gonna
head back home the story picks up where
he's actually seven days away from this
ultimate deadline that he's given
himself and he hasn't made it yet so you
know he is an actor but I believe the
story has this universal theme this
universal idea doesn't doesn't it's not
just an acting story you know he could
easily be a painter or musician anyone
with a dream and anyone that does come
up short I believe we all face this I've
certainly face this hair care that you
know with just being on the edge in
terms of you know what am i doing it
right I even chase this dream is that
something you can relate to Richard
that's something I believe everyone can
relate to in reality doesn't matter if
you're an artist or a corp and a career
oriented person we want to everybody
needs that a plan and most people set up
deadlines for themselves because if you
don't have deadlines you can move maybe
better accomplished anything in life on
our first project we worked on together
we have set a date saying whether or not
we have money now we're going to start
shooting to make going to start shooting
and make this
and that's exactly what we did
fortunately for us again money where it
is five you know what we're going to do
with this campaign what the direction
we're going to take is we're going to
start bringing you into the world of on
the people behind the scenes and maybe
even the people that you saw the actors
they click the calves like the crew and
we're going to give you a glimpse of
their personal stories you're going to
find out more about me you're going to
find out more about Karen is holding the
camera and you're going to find out more
about this gentleman here so with that
we want to thank you for your support
i'm gonna go ahead and finish my fortune
cookie now Thank you Thank